you
[Music]
thank you all for coming today
today viral shot and Elliott Saba from
Julia computing are going to be talking
about differentiable programming in
Julia in particular the zygote automatic
differentiation tool Julia is a very
interesting language for scientific
computation data science machine
learning I've I've been spending a lot
more time on it recently if and if
you're interested in any of those fields
you might want to check it out as well
so with that I'll turn it over to all
right folks I guess you guys can hear me
at the back right I don't know if this
is or do I have to stand here I'm fine
right okay so we're gonna do this talk
in two parts I think the talk is is is
mainly just is going to be fairly
accessible and general-purpose and and
I'm going to talk a little bit about
Julia a little bit about the the ad
tools that we have a little bit about
the applications that we are putting
together to give a broader context and
Elliott is gonna actually focus on on a
few demos and talk through the system
and how it actually works just to
convince you guys that is not all fully
vaporware that there's actually some
stuff that works there so please feel
free to interrupt and ask questions I
that's okay right yeah so that's just
just generally easier for us to address
questions as they come up all right so
with that we're gonna jump into this
quick question who's never heard of
Julia at all here before this talk maybe
says maybe maybe just one or two people
there okay so then I won't spend way too
much time talking about Julia itself and
and focus a little bit more on on what
we are here for which is talking about
the differentiable programming and just
by way of background there is this
general you know trend or you know in in
though in the field of machine learning
or AI or you know languages all these
fields put together that there's going
to be the software 2.0 platform deep
learning was the first
iteration of it with the neural networks
and the fact that you have back
propagation and you're able to train
these models with all these weights and
and then you know that train of thought
has increasingly led to a generalization
from saying hey why not
you know why just neural nets can we do
can we do more arbitrary forms of
programs can we differentiate them can
we
you know optimize you know more complex
models and what if the models were just
simply you know regular programs as
opposed to being a specific you know
domain-specific language or a specific
you know kind of abstractions can we can
we generalize it and the idea being that
you know if it's just code then you
don't need a tense a tensor framework
like tensor flow or PI torch or one of
these things you you know you just write
your regular program and then you hand
it over to the optimizer and it does its
thing and and gives you you know guess
your training then gives you the weights
all that good stuff
and a couple years ago we published a
blog post on machine learning and
programming languages where we made this
argument and we've been you know add
this since then ever since we you know
we've been publishing and talking about
our work we've seen Chris Latner start
off a project at Google which is the
Swift for tensorflow project with a very
similar idea you know again focused on
differentiable programming which is the
term that that we started using having
first heard about it from yan laocoon
and so that's the general you know
background here we presented some of
these ideas at new reps last year at the
ml sis workshop so we presented julia
working on different kinds of hardware
and i'm going to talk about it next
zygor which is the underlying tool that
we use for differentiable programming it
works on the on the on the ir form and
the flux which is a deep learning
framework which has been built on top of
you know julian zygote and all its
capabilities and it's a pure julia
library all right
so what what is I got at the end of the
day it's you know it's it's basically
you know doing exactly what you know
this transform that shows that's shown
here and the details are in this paper
don't unroll adjoin differentiating SSA
form programs by Mike Ennis but
basically if you have a simple program
zygotes able to transform it so that you
you can you know compute what the output
is
and then also compute the derivatives in
in reverse mode and when when I switch
over to Elliott he's gonna you know say
a little bit more about how zygote works
under the hood and and why it's good at
doing what it does but I think maybe for
the audience here it may be fairly you
know well-known that you know compared
to creator based systems system like
zygote that works on source to source
transformation is usually better and has
many many benefits but if not you know
we will touch upon that as we go forward
so some applications so so now some of
these applications do not have to do
with zygote yet but are more about you
know capabilities right so if you think
about machine learning or AI if you know
if you if you use these words but if you
think about how these things are
developing and growing and how you know
the concepts are emerging there's
there's basically two things that power
the modern deep learning revolution
right one is hardware so you know
started with CPUs and then GPUs and then
you have TP use and and various kinds of
specialized hardware so that's that's a
given right if you want to be able to
you know run programs that run on these
large amounts of data you need to be
able to target all these different kinds
of hardware and that's the first set of
slides I'm going to just quickly show
through and then the second part of it
is source to source transformational
source ad which is the the whole
differentiable programming part of it
so one without the other doesn't make
sense and you know you're just going to
jump into the hardware parts really
quickly this is this is a large
variational inference calculation a
Bayesian inference calculation that was
done on an Astro date
that it's about 60 terabytes of data
650-thousand course Giulia running
multi-threaded across the whole cluster
just works and I we were led to believe
by the astrophysicist that is one of the
largest scientific optimization problems
ever solved so this one did a joint
optimization of 180 million light
sources in order to solve this problem
of building a catalog of the universe
the underlying computations were done on
strange matrix structures not just you
know regular dense matrices or even
regular sparse matrices but matrices
that that had you know different kinds
of sparsity patterns and different kind
of storage patterns that had been
implemented for this project again the
point being here that julia is running
at scale is able to work on you know
general-purpose data structures that
have been implemented in julia and not
just the ones that ship inside of julia
and you'll see this theme repeatedly in
in many of the things that we talk about
all right so that was a case on CPUs the
next one is is GPUs and the same julia
tool chains that generate code for CPUs
is also you know through LLVM used to
generate code for GPUs and if you're a
julia programmer you can actually write
native julia code that will compile to
the to the PT x assembly and execute on
the GPU and here's a pretty simple
example of offer vector ad that's
written purely natively in julia it it's
got the same CUDA programming model at
the lowest level and that's what
generates the code the code that's
generated is on the is on your
right-hand side and you pretty much get
all the CUDA n strains intrinsics this
PMD programming model the memory
management all that stuff the what what
we do win so for example when you're
using Julia's machine learning
capabilities on the GPU what what's
happening under the hood is that there
are no real libraries that are also
implemented natively in June
using the cooler native package which is
also you know implemented in julia and
then that you know generates the LLVM so
a large part of the julia ecosystem even
when running on GPUs is implemented in
julia itself it's as fast as the CUDA
see implementation for example so this
is a set of standardized benchmarks that
that were published and it turns out
that julia is sometimes faster than CUDA
C++ and sometimes slower on this
benchmark suite so I would say on on
average if I was if I was looking at
this as a person looking to adopt
Julia's GPU compiler I think this is
this suggests that is pretty good why is
it faster I think the the answer is a
bit strange I think it's because the
LLVM that we use is something that
Google has optimized the open-source
LLVM back-end generation that we use has
slightly different passes than nvidias
proprietary passes and you know some of
the internal code gen just ends up being
much better in the open-source version
than the proprietary version so no deep
reason per se it's it's just that it's
evidence that we've used to convince
nvidia that you know here you guys
should probably you know open-source
more of your stuff rather than keeping
it in-house clearly you're not gaining
much out of it yeah yeah there so this
was published on the Nvidia blog and and
this was a point of contention that you
know they were pretty unhappy about it
but but they ran with it they did
publish it eventually you know more and
more domain-specific processors coming
out in this space of the TP use with all
their weirdness and their architecture I
think this itself could be a complete
talk right now yeah but we will just sum
it up so TPS have their own backends and
their own compilers and their own tools
but from Julia we are able to generate
actually execute on the TPU and we were
able to run Julie on a complete TPU pod
and achieve is this 4.3 16 1/2 1/2 load
1/2
the flaw is that the right word for it
it's yeah it's hard to know what a flop
really means these days I think better
up is what I hear nowadays peddle ups
and exit ups so yep so that was on the
resin at 50 so that's now this one was
actually running completely in zygote
right there's a backward back
propagation was completely in zygote on
a pod we got a you know Jeff Dean was
excited about it so we put you know we
captured his tweet and stored it in our
presentations for future use but but
this really I think does capture right
the ability to have abstractions that
run on a variety of hardware and you
know that have native capabilities for
for differentiation is a powerful tool
for writing new kinds of models and you
know maybe we can do away with
frameworks and just and you know write
codes in ways that are you know that
that actually makes sense and that are
scalable a lot of what we talk about
right now depends on rests upon the fact
that the underlying implementation of
the libraries and and all the julia
libraries that we call are all native
julia all the way down and the more of
the libraries and dependencies that are
julia the less black boxes for the the
ad tool that you know that's that's
that's processing them right if you run
into a certain Fortran routine your ad
tool has to give up and be like hey give
me the derivative of this Fortran
routine otherwise I can't move forward
and so the ability to have as much of
your stuff in julia all the way down
actually is a pretty powerful story for
us and this was something we started out
in the early days of julia itself right
that we wanted to be able to write
high-performance kernels natively in the
language itself so over the last 10
years as we you know raised towards
julia 1.0 one of the things that the
community built was about 2500
open-source libraries which are by and
large you know pure julia and and and
that that continues right we try to
avoid using crossing language boundaries
and while that was good for Julia's
performance it turned out that as as we
started doing more and more ad stuff
that oh now we can actually even
differentiate through some of these
things with with with a lot of you know
with with more ease
and then otherwise we have friends at
MIT who claim that they can do cross
language ad and we fully believe that
with things like LLVM that may be
possible at some point but you know
given how difficult it already is even
in Julia itself I think you know we're
gonna wait for those tools to emerge
when they do so as a result we have
best-in-class packages in many domains
you know these are just some of the ones
that are that I'm articulating out here
but there's many more now I'm going to
just fly through the rest of this
presentation so we can actually get
through the demos do we have a time
check let's back up there oh right there
okay so one of the key things that we've
done so one of the you know why why does
everything being in Julia under the hood
actually matter right why does every
library have to be in the same language
I mean Julia happens to be the language
that we are talking about but I think
you know at Microsoft the fact that
everything is in dotnet is is you know
it's something that wouldn't be lost
upon many of you and and you definitely
know what what all it offers the
compiler in terms of other kinds of
optimizations it can do and the kinds of
tooling you can build so here's an
example of Julia's differential
equations package which is one of the
best differential equation packages out
there the most complete ones and and
flux which is the you know the native
Julia neural network framework and and
we are able to just combine these things
and do new neural Odie's without having
to rewrite either of these packages
here's an example of adding measurements
to our jail to differential equations so
the ability to get error bounds or
sensitivities out of a program which was
never designed to work with error bars
right so the measurements are gel is a
fantastic package that does that and
here's an example where you just you
know you're you're sort of simulating I
think this is a pendulum if I'm not
mistaken yes so this is a simple OD it's
a pendulum and instead of passing in
floating point values you're passing in
these measurement values now so every
measurement is basically you know it's
propagating it's exactly up there right
so I'm starting out the calculations
with some kind of an uncertainty so the
value of G which is the gravitational
constant is nine point seven nine
- something right and so that plus or
minus operator has been overloaded by
that package in order to represent these
uncertainties and then you've got the
length also with some one certainty and
now you run through this whole problem
and you get the analytical solution
which is plotted there and the
differential equations package just
happens to be written in Julia it does
not know anything about the measurements
package but then when the measurements
package showed up of you're able to just
plug these things in you know together
and and it composed and worked really
well so we're now in a partnership with
the University of Maryland at Baltimore
taking all these amazing improvements in
ODS and combining it with all the all
the machine learning models and applying
it to personalized medicine and you know
there's there's there's all kinds of
interesting things we're working on
there
another example is neural SDS in finance
so again I'm not going to talk too much
about it but once you're an ordinary
differential equation it's not a stretch
of imagination to start thinking about
stochastic ones and you know again the
neural SD is with error bounds all of
that stuff works out and it's it's it's
it's a direction where modern finance is
beginning to move in as you combine
machine learning with the typical kinds
of traditional PDS that you saw in
finance so here's some fun things there
jump is another Julia gulia
domain-specific language for operations
research some you know at the core of
jump what you know again you have to you
know as the solvers do their job you
have to compute your gradients and and
you know that's another application for
differentiable programming in julia this
one is actually not using zygote at the
moment
it's it has its own differentiation
capabilities it tends to predate zygote
but this was used to solve a very
complex school bus routing problem for
the boston public school system and
there was a team from MIT that did that
in julien and one more applications of
jump are in climate modeling energy
modeling and all kinds of fun fun
applications that I can't talk about
today and talk in tower talks of their
own
this portion of what I'm gonna say
actually I'm not gonna say anything but
it's about how Julius implemented under
the hood and how the type system and the
method dispatch works but in order to
get to zygote I'm just going to sort of
you know go through these things and
what I wanted to point out is that
Julius type system is actually fairly
robust and has been stressed
significantly and you know while you
think that you know oh you know we can
handle different numeric number types
and different vector types and and small
little cute things like that you know
maybe even like different matrix types
maybe it doesn't really scale the real
life problems right is what someone
might think but here's you know here's
the the representation of layers of the
vgg nineteen neural net right so you
know the neural net itself is not not
that difficult but the stuff that's
inside the type system that it's working
with is is this unreadable wall of text
it's the type of each layer yeah so this
this right here is representing it's a
type that represents every computation
that's inside of the vgg nineteen neural
network so you can see it starts out
with this thing that says immutable
chain it's got a tuple inside of it and
then it moves into a convolution that's
doing a rail ooh activation inside of it
and so the reason why we have this is
because this is actually used for when
work compiling to specialized harbor
like TP use where we need to have a
single giant static code chunk we can't
have any dynamic lookups of what code
should I run next running on the device
because we don't have the full julia
compiler running on the device itself so
to compile a single giant piece of code
sends it off to the device and in order
to do that we build this giant
essentially in the type system a
description of the entire computation
that we're going to do the device is
typically a GPU
although could be other things right
exactly right all right and then you
know there are actually there are
actually academics so this is work done
at Northeastern who are now formalizing
the type system inside of julia and
they've taken the approach of so julia
julia and it's compiler and type system
told this approach of let's start out
with something that we think you know is
going to work in two
and build a type system together and and
piece it together without actually
starting from you know the ground up
like like something like Haskell might
probably have done but there's a there's
a group of researchers at Northeastern
who've taken a large body of julia code
formalized some of this work and this is
the formal representation of the julia
type system i don't know what this means
myself but i think there are people in
our compiler team who do know what this
means the interesting thing about this
was that after they did all this
formalization they actually found a
couple of bugs in the type system and
they filed issues and we actually fixed
them so that's what gives me a lot of
you know comfort right like the fact
that someone's done this and you know
there there's there's there's proofs and
all that stuff under the hood also the
good thing was that if they were two
fairly minor bugs that we you know
hadn't seen before but it would have
been much more worrisome if there were
like a slew of them another fun thing is
be float16 i really would love to talk
about this and pull out my julia session
and do a little demo of julius be
float16 rhythmatic but again i'm not
going to do that today but i would
encourage you to if you google and nick
Himes or rather if you're Microsoft and
I apologize this being so sir search for
six search for Nick Holmes blog on on
harmonic series and and 16-bit floats
and it's it's a fun little exercise of
how you could you know what happens in
all these different number types and
arithmetic systems this is a sum that's
supposed to actually diverge if you if
you had infinite precision and and and
arithmetic but it turns out that in be
float16 it adds up to sixty five instead
of infinity but then as you increase the
precision you get much larger sums the
cool thing is that in Julia you just
changed the input type of the of the
program and it just pretty much works
alright so it's a large community this
number is actually fairly old I forgot
to update this number on my slide but we
are actually at eight million downloads
today about half of them are downloads
through docker hub and which suggests to
me that a lot of people are using julia
you know and at companies and
professionally as opposed to sort of
mostly
research community so a lot of people
feel like Julia's only used by
researchers and it's not really being
used in production but that's actually
no longer the case especially since
julia 1.0 came out last year you can
kind of tell when julia 1.0 came out
with that with the abrupt jump in the
number of stars on github lots of
interesting books coming out on julia
now and these are just specific books on
julia itself there are even there are
books out there that that are not about
Julia itself but a but not about some
kind of an academic topic that happens
to just use Julia as the language of
instruction but but these are some of
the best books out there especially I
think this will really think julia book
is a pretty good one for introducing
julia itself - you know two programmers
who are not familiar with julia and then
i think the high performance julia book
out there is actually a pretty good one
that shows off things in julia that you
would not as a regular program or expect
you know things that are maybe
counterintuitive or interesting about
Julia but then this is a book by Stephen
Boyd at Stanford so this is the basis of
all of Stanford's linear algebra comes
so the Julia companion
that's another book from Stanford
Graduate optimization class that's
traditional numerical analysis Julianne
operations research computer vision the
book on the corner out there is is a
typical data science book with all the
you know how do I load tabular data and
manipulate it and how do I do simple
learning models on it and stuff like
that this is this this the algorithm for
optimization book especially if you're
if you're into optimization of any kind
I think it's it's a beautiful book and I
just I just like showing off a few pages
just because of how how beautiful each
page in the book is and so that's what
it looks like it's got Julia Code and it
comes you know with with a package
beautiful pictures charts everything the
entire book is generated in Julia itself
so I highly encourage it tons of people
are teaching Julia this these are some
of the universities teaching Julia some
logos that we could fit on the slides
and I'm proud to and you know say that
we actually were awarded the Wilkinson
prize this year for for Juliet's it's
given out every four years for numerical
software and you know I've been
personally very excited about it because
a lot of the people who I looked upon as
you know those having built the core
numerical libraries were awarded it in
the past and so it was a recognition not
just for the three of us who started
Julia but you know many of us you know
folks like Elliott or you know hundreds
of people in the community you've put
this thing together and Julia Corn 2019
this is the fifth or maybe the sixth one
I think is the sixth one that's gonna be
in Baltimore next there's actually
hundreds of people who show up at the
conference sponsorship opportunities are
open should you know should there be
some interest that's that's one of my
roles that Julia Khan I'm also the the
person who has to raise the funds for it
so so that's a slide in every talk
alright so with that I'm gonna hand over
to Elliott to talk about zygote and show
a few of the demos of what we do is I go
today yeah all right thanks Rob
all right so let's switch gears real
quick I do not have beautiful slides but
what I do have is Jupiter notebooks and
in case any of you guys want to follow
along what we're going to do is we'll
follow along afterwards we can send you
the notebooks but we're going to do is
we're going to get a feel for what doing
this kind of differential programming
feels like in Julia and to see kind of
what its capabilities are and what we
can what we get away with it with the
language in its current state so first
off we're going to start with a basic
linear regression example so we're going
to have some coefficients that are
initially unknown we'll have some ground
truth coefficients we're trying to
figure out what those coefficients are
looking at some noisy data so the first
thing I'm going to do is I'm just going
to load the package and we are going to
start off by using things that are not
just like matrices and and bias
scalars and things like that we're going
to use an actual object here we have a
linear regression struct it's going to
have a matrix inside of it that's
weights it's gonna have a single value
inside of its bias and it will have a
name and the only reason I'm putting a
name here is to show that I can mix
things that are going to be
automatically learned and I'm mix things
that are not automatically learned our
optimization algorithm is not going to
do anything with the name but we don't
have to do anything special to tell it
hey don't pay attention to this part of
the program or do pay attention to this
part of the program it's all going to be
kind of implicit in how we are writing
the writing the optimization problem so
here I define a type called linear
regression that has these things inside
of it and I'll define a single
constructor that takes in a number of
parameters and name and then I just
initialized the weights to some random
vector that's a 1 by n params length the
base gets initialized to 0 and the name
just gets copied in I'm going to define
kind of two operations two verbs upon
these upon this type my lake can people
read this is this readable good the
first one is just predict kind of a the
forward the forward pass of our model as
it were or we pass in a model we pass in
an X and we just take the weights times
X plus the bias in julia this dot plus
thing means broadcasting so if the
weights times x is say a matrix and i
have a scalar bias it's going to
automatically broadcast the bias up to
be a matrix and do the matrix matrix in
or multiplication we're also going to
define a loss so the loss is going to
measure how close we are to some target
output so I pass in my model and X and
I'll run predict on that and then I'm
just gonna take the l2 norm between that
prediction we could call it y hat if we
want and the actual true y our
optimization problem that are solving is
to reduce this loss to zero we're then
going to have our ground truth weights
just values that I typed out in ground
truth bias we're going to create a kind
of a training data set which is just a
bunch of random noise in this F
we'll have our true Y which is applying
V weights and the bias to this X to
create that Y and then we have a little
bit of noise we add on to X to make sure
that we don't have an exact solution we
have to do some kind of some kind of
least squares fit or this that's the way
we would think about if we were writing
this from a kind of closed for
mathematical solution but the way that
we're going to do this is not with
clothes for mathematics I wanted to do
this with automatic differentiation and
so what we'll do is we'll create our
model which starts out with those
randomly initialized parameters and then
we will see our very first usage of
zygote here we say zygote I want you to
calculate the gradients upon the model
for this piece of code where this piece
of code takes in the model as a
parameter and it calculates the loss
between the output of the model for the
very first example of X and the very
first ground truth value so if I run
this it says X is not a fine because I
didn't run any of these so if I run this
what happens is it says the grads object
and the very first time you run this it
takes a little while because Zygo is pre
compiling a bunch of code it has to
compile all the backwards passes of
everything that's involved in this
function etc but the second time you run
it it's blazingly fast which is a common
theme with julia the first time you run
it has to compile a bunch of stuff the
second time it's blazingly fast so when
you execute that gradient function is
doing a source-to-source transformation
of the model aust code that's right then
that is
that's exactly right so I'm gonna talk
about what it is and I'm gonna talk
about how it did it so the first one
what it returns to us is it returns this
thing that looks kind of scary is a
tuple that's wrapping a ref value etc
but you can see in the middle somewhere
there's this thing that says okay
weights is this bias is that name is
nothing and so what this is doing is it
has analyzed the parameter that we
passed in the model it has figured out
how that model how the parameters that
model have affected the output and then
in order to have the output go to zero
where the output here is the return
value of the loss function it says I
need to change this value of the weights
vector to be you know 1.19 less than it
is right now etc etc so these are all
the gradients it has that it has
computed and yes the way that it's doing
this is it has analyzed the julia source
code of everything involved in this loss
function I mean everything from addition
to multiplication to even the the
operation of just here in this predict
thing reaching into the model object
which is nothing that have anything
specialized about zygote baked into it
it's just a normal julia function normal
julia object and grabbing the the
weights value out of it and yes it takes
that it finds the inverse operations for
each individual operation puts them
together into a program compiles that
program and then runs it backward
slicing
i mean in general it seems hard to do
with aliasing is it how do you deal with
ABC yeah so aliasing in this case
meaning like overriding values as i go
throughout the computation right no what
I mean is suppose you know you're trying
to find you know which parameters are
affecting that for example its WN biases
but not that not the weight name
whatever it is
so can you imagine that you know there's
some movements of conditionals where
it's not clear by you they're slicing
back I mean how do you it's not clear
which of the feeds are active in games
right so okay so first off the way we
decide which things it's going to be
paying attention to is by the values
that we pass into gradient here so when
I pass the model in here that means it's
explicitly going to be looking at model
and everything inside of it secondly the
way that as I go works is it takes your
source code and then it's I'm going to
go back to that slide that they're all
had in his in his example he has a he
has a slide that shows kind of the the
source to source translation that zygote
does right here so what this is showing
is it's showing I have a function and I
want to create the dual program there we
go I want to create the dual program the
dual program is a compute two things
first the forward pass value and second
it's going to compute a program to allow
me to calculate the backwards past it
the background has passed program so
here what it gets translated to is the
first part looks largely the same the
second part it's returning both the
actual forwards value and a new function
that is going to compute gradients for
each individual step where this grading
is correlated this this gradients with
that this gradients of that etc now we
calculate the value for every single you
know we calculate the the inverse value
the the gradients or the sensitivities
for everything that's used on the left
and then we allow our optimizing
compiler to do dead code elimination and
all that good stuff to get rid of things
that we don't care about so in some
sense we don't really directly specify
oh actually just skip straight to x and
y we let the compiler do that because we
already have an optimizing compiler
that's very aggressively drops things
the zygote paper goes into a little bit
more detail about how these what we call
pullback functions the the function that
map's from the kind of Delta Y to map
back to Delta X for each individual
operation we have kind of a library
that's already been defined for here's
what the pull back for multiplication is
here's what the pull back for addition
is etc etc we have the ability in
zygotes to define our own custom
gradients for things for instance if I
have a convolution operation that calls
coup DNN on NVIDIA hardware we don't
have the Julius source code for that
actual convolution obviously but Nvidia
gives us a gradient function that we can
call to compute on the GPU automatically
and so we have ways that we can very
simply hook that function call up so it
says when you see this function call
call this function to get the gradient
as well for just general giulia code you
know we have the basic building blocks
already put in there for things that are
more complex where you say I do have the
Julia Code but I want to have my own
Julia custom gradient not have it be
automatically analyzed by zygote because
it will generate subpar code you can of
course do that as well with the same
functionality as we would use to do it
for NVIDIA black boxes and things like
that all right so to peel this grads
object apart a little bit it's a tuple
containing one element for argument to
gradient so by saying sub one we're
saying we want to get the gradients for
the very first argument that's passed in
which is the model object next we say
this linear regression object is a
mutable object which is kind of a
implementation detail that we won't talk
about too much but we've peeled that
apart with this empty brackets and now
we get a named tuple so we can actually
ask for things like what is grads dot
weights and we get out an array and we
can take this array and directly combine
it with the weights that are stored in
our model in order to actually do an
update step and then continue with new
examples and and learn
a little bit so that's exactly what
we're going to do we define our own
little stochastic gradient descent
update rule with a you know a learning
rate and all that good stuff that I'm
sure everyone here sees in their dreams
and then we will just run this for a
couple iterations across our entire
training set and so when we do this we
are just calculating gradient updating
calculating gradient updating calculate
gradient updating for every different
column in our training set so we had I
think 10,000 different different
examples and when we do that we can look
at the ground truth weights that we had
here and the model weights here and
they're pretty close and so this is kind
of a an intuitive or a simple example
showing that yes indeed we can optimize
a toy problem with zygote just using
these gradients and we built essentially
everything from scratch there's there's
no fancy deep learning code hidden here
or anything like that everything is just
as it appears oh we can look at the bias
as well and yeah we get something that's
pretty close but of course this is a
pretty simple problem all we really have
is one matrix multiply and in addition
so in order to step beyond that a little
bit we're gonna look at a slightly more
complex example are there any questions
about this before I move on okay great
so we're going to do is we are going to
move on to a a differentiable ray tracer
so we have a simple ray tracer that one
of our JSOC students wrote this ray
tracer can generate images with simple
geometry point source lights you know
kind of arbitrary geometry camera
orientation etc etc and what we're going
to do is we are going to render a scene
have that as the target scene then
render a slightly different scene and
have Zygo figure out what are the
gradients upon things like the position
of a point source light given these
pixels and so it's going to have to make
its way back through the entire
rendering function in order to figure
out how the position of a point source
light would have
affect the pixels on screen and so here
I have kind of a basic scene
configuration or have a camera that's
centered at 0 0 negative 5 in Xyz space
etc etc I have a function that calls
render I have a function call for a show
image and we'll just kind of see what
this looks like
I'm not going to dig that deeply into
the ray tracer code because that's not
why we're here but it's all open source
you can go on line and look at it and
you can even render your own your own
scenes if you wish alright so we're
going to create a scene with two
triangles and a single point light and
I'm using this tool called interact
which allows me to have kind of little
widgets that I can drag around in the in
the jupiter notebook and so we can kind
of interactively see what this scene
looks like and of course i have to
recompile everything there we go alright
so this is the scene if i drag this
around I'm changing the point source
light and it's kind of interactively
rendering it and so we can set this as
for instance this could be our target
image we would say we want the scene to
look like this and if we have a second
scene that has the point source lights
incorrectly set so here the light is
right here whereas here I have it in the
top-left corner we can then ask was I
goat all right I want you to do the same
thing we did before but in this case our
training set is just pushing image
through calculate pixel wise distance
minimize that trace backwards through it
and find the gradient upon the point
light so I'll do that for 50 iterations
again I'm gonna be calling gradients
here I'm passing in the entire scene and
the light so the scene being the
description of where the triangles are
the lights being the description of
where the light is including things like
it's its intensity it's basically
everything that that describes the scene
and all I do inside here as I say all
right render the image take the mean
squared error will show the loss as well
and we're
the loss so some of the cool stuff that
we're showing here is Julie is a very
dynamic language we can do pretty much
whatever we want inside of here there's
a lot of if statements there's a lot of
form while loops inside this renderer
it's doing kind of the whole control
flow thing and we can even do things
like IO and and whatever we want inside
these gradients there's no like
constraints really on what we can what
we can do in here except for operations
that are not yet supported by zygote so
for instance here like I can I can print
out to the console in the middle of my
program that's being differentiated and
that that works just fine because it
doesn't affect the loss so it's just
going to get eliminated in the dead code
elimination when we compile the
backwards pass and so what we're going
to do is we're gonna catch the gradients
and then we will just directly update
the light position with the position
from the gradients again we're saying
grad sub-2 here because it's the second
argument to gradient and then every 10
iterations we are going to show the
image of what the scene looks like and
every iteration we're going to see the
loss and this will take a little while
because it's running on a single core on
my laptop it's rendering a 200 by 200
image and again the very first time you
run something it's it takes a little
while while it's running are there any
questions yes only data that the model
sees are like the features yes does also
take into account it's like like the
coordinates of the light sources right
so so what it sees okay so the so what
zygote sees is I go sees the entire
program so I go sees I have seen
description in large program and then
image out and what we do is we say I
have this target image it does not see
the target coordinates all it is is the
target image and it says in order to
make this image closer to that image
where I had the bright light source in
the top left corner how do I need to
change the inputs in order to better
match that out
and so in order to do that what it has
to do is it has to build a source to
source like in version of the entire
program and the way it does it is
describes best in the paper but as we've
been talking about before it takes kind
of each individual operation figures out
what's the dual of this so for instance
if it's addition then if you have a plus
B equals y then if you have Delta Y that
just turns into Delta Y gets applied to
a and Delta Y gets applied to B if you
have sine then its cosine you know etc
etc etc and so for something like this
it's going to be doing a lot of sines of
cosines for all the shading it's going
to be doing it has to track control flow
so when you have when you have an if
statement it has to record which if
statement it went through so when it's
coming back it applies the operations
back through that if statement as
opposed to something like a tracing
differentially sorry a tracing automatic
differentiation toolkit we don't we
don't record all the operations inside
of the data as it flows through we
actually build a program that will do
the inverse of what the program was the
first time you ran it so when you when
you run the program through the first
time it's going to keep track of which
if they went through and that will be
just kind of hard baked into the program
that it compiles for the backward pass
does that answer your question
yes so what is different inputs produced
a different path through the ray tracer
how would that be handled right so
that's why inside of this for loop I'm
coloring gradients every single time so
for a particular set of inputs it will
compile that particular you know
backwards pass and then for a different
set of inputs your backwards path may
change the Julia compiler is pretty good
at not compiling something twice if it
if it doesn't have to so the amount of
compilation work needed to do it the
second and third time is very minimal
but yes the gradients like backwards
pass code could change but it has to be
pretty it has to be pretty drastic
changes I mean Julie is a very dynamic
language so you can do things like
redefine the the meaning of addition on
two integers halfway through your
program and
we'll just work but the more of that
dynamic stuff you do the more
recompilation we're going to have to do
it's not recommended to do that yeah it
breaks a surprising amount of the
language if you in kind of normal
everyday usage it's not that it's not
that big of a difference critically
things like for loops and while loops
and things like that the number of
iterations and all that kind of stuff
that is not hard baked into the reverse
the reverse pass so when you have a for
loop in your forward code that's going
to turn into recursion in the in the
backwards pass and it can dynamically do
just as much recursion as you can
dynamically do just as many iterations
as you had in the forward pass without
needing to change the program so things
like that are dynamic other things are
statically baked in any other questions
yes I'm if I'm sampling from a
distribution in my forward pass just
Giulia have I need to fall handling for
that for the automatic differentiation
or if I'm interested like using a couple
different strategies for that
did you lis handle that well when you
say sampling from a distribution you
mean like from a from a random process
or something right
so for those kinds of things it's going
to depend on how the internal like the
internals of the distribution are
designed so pulling out random numbers
like yes you can do it I think most
likely you don't want to leave that
completely up to zygote you want to have
a well-defined gradient and so I would
expect the distributions people who are
using zygote to be writing their own I
know there are people who do that I have
never used it personally so I would have
to look into that to see exactly how
they do it but I I know people who have
distributions that that use it with as I
go in order to do differentiation back
through those samplings but again I
don't know exactly how they do it
any other questions maybe what we're all
saying so what's the right way to think
about this versus you know something in
your execution
by torture danceability the execution
yeah so probably the single biggest
difference is again this slide because
with eager execution you're going to be
so you're going to have a lot of the
same benefits you're going to be able to
write the code that you want as long as
the basic building blocks are there
you're going to be able to use it in a
dynamic and an interactive way but
probably the single biggest difference
is the calculation of the backwards pass
because we're able to do this
source-to-source translation thing and
then run that back through our optimizer
we can generate very fast inverse
reverse mode ad some of the benchmarks
that we have in the paper show disk as
compared to things like pi torch being
like orders of magnitude faster and the
reason for that is because this source
code is able to be jammed all together
we're able to do fusion we're able to
treat all the single cohesive program
rather than as something that when you
add one operation you don't know what
the next operation will be because it's
kind of an eager mode adding it on one
at a time kind of approach amazing
combined step the first time you run and
you do all the stuff doing that that's
right
yes and so is it possible to do an
optimizing compiler on a trace where
potentially something you later place
the first time on the stray space
systems but the equivalent thing need to
actually try to optimize the trace I
think you could I not yeah yeah they do
but that's the right way to think about
that's what's missing there basically
you're saying you do have an
optimization pass on top of this thing
there is
in these other great spaces they don't
yes I think that it is difficult with
the Tres based systems because many of
them are built as kind of you have glue
between these high performance kernels
that are already predetermined and so in
order to bridge that glue in order to
kind of fuse things together and get
that all working together you would need
everything to be in kind of a common
language right you would need to have
everything the same ir and then optimize
a compiler that can read that IR but the
difference is that you don't program
intensive flow you program in Python
exactly yeah exactly and so that's the
different that then the glue that really
forms that orchestrates the tensorflow
logic and even so more so much my torch
it's written in Python and PI torches
largely written in C++ so you have these
two language environments are invisible
to each other
and so that's with this sort of what
this is you there's no I are like
extending or something that's know so
that you can raise itself is not going
to have on the blue code the trace will
have only accelerations so that is kind
of see through the su + + right so you
pretty much just it's a social problem
right I mean the the fact that there is
a compiler doesn't know the intrinsic
sides of each of the accelerations so I
think I think so the fundamental problem
is if I were to have just XY operations
and I have my trace and it's this
beautiful stack of X Y operations then I
hand that whole thing one with the X
play compiler and it can generate them
together yes they can do exactly what
we're doing but the reality is that
rarely is the case because if I am if
I'm just doing V g19 for instance yes
every I have a convolution followed by a
pool followed by an activation and it's
you know it's all it all just flows very
naturally all those things are excellent
operations and penciler flows compiler
can probably most shut all together very
nicely but as soon as I step outside of
the painted lines of X la I will have
code that cannot do that an interesting
analog to this is the code the work that
we did to move this on to TP use
Google's you know AI
processor we can't run anything except
Excel a on those that's the only thing
that we can do so we had to lower all of
our julia code to excel a in order to do
that Saigo was the tool that we used to
do that we just defined custom gradients
for all the TPU array types and things
like that we were able to mash it
together and we were able to get very
similar performance to what google's
tensorflow stuff does on the same kinds
of hardware so that's kind of an
existence proof that yes this this
approach is pretty similar to what you
can do if everything you have is
excellet but most people don't have just
100% excellent almost nobody does yeah
except for except if you're doing the
really standard stuff that they've
already did all their all their work for
and it's a lot of work to add more
excellet kernels to your system and so
we'd rather live in a world where we can
write the obvious code and it kind of
quote unquote
just works it's also worth pointing out
that even if you had a pure Python
libraries right which doesn't exist in
the real world right because most Python
libraries go into site on and you pretty
much are lost out there but even if you
have the pure Python libraries a lot of
the stuff that the tensorflow and pie
tart systems do when they compile
they're not really Python anymore you
know it's it's something that
syntactically looks like Python but is
actually a different system under the
hood any other questions
alright with that we are going to take a
look at our last example things almost
fun one yeah so I will do this quickly
because I think we run out of time
essentially what we're going to do is we
have a physical system that's being
stimulated this physical system is a
trebuchet that launches a projectile and
attempts to hit a target and we are
going to train a neural network to be
able to control parameters that goes
into this ordinary differential equation
solver
that's calculating things like gravity
versus wind air resistance etc etc and
we are going to try and learn to shoot a
target with a trebuchet through the man
backpropagation and so what we have here
is we have a neat visualization that was
again written off by one of our G sock
students we love our G sock students the
google Summer of Code students they they
do a lot of good work for us and we get
them hooked in the community and they
keep on helping us out even they're not
getting paid open-source is wonderful
isn't it
and so here we're going to have kind of
a simulation where we have a trebuchet
that shoots a projectile and we print
out some statistics down here such as
the maximum distance that is traveled
its current height etc etc etc let me
see if I can reduce this a little bit so
we can see more good it turns out that
this is not just a single simple or easy
solver that you actually need to have a
route finder inside it in order to
figure out when you hit the ground right
so so it's already sort of some you know
it always more code than you would you
don't need to write it's not just like
five lines of an Euler method with a
neural network right it's very fair
amount of stuff under the hood right one
of the one of the things is that where
we've got here's a little helper
function to help us get the distance for
a particular for a particular set of
parameters so for instance add some wind
then it reduces the distances able to
fly at cetera et cetera we are going to
use this is an example that's actually
not using zygote it's using a different
automatic differentiation tool under the
hood but the bate same basic philosophy
applies it's just that this work
predates is not yet using zygonian this
works the dates I go yeah it will
eventually be using as I go with
essentially like five percent difference
in the in the actual text you see on
screen and so you can see that we have
very similar api's here for this package
as well just calculating gradients on
the shoot function with these particular
parameters etc and so we're able to get
our gradients on the
parameters after shooting this through
an eau de silver which is great that's
what we want and so what we're going to
do is we're going to apply this gradient
to increase this value like it's asked
us to and indeed we get a little bit
farther by making that little change so
we show that yes the gradients are
indeed sane they are indeed doing what
we want and so what we're going to do is
we're going to zoom down here really
quick because we're low on time and
we're just going to get to the
simulations so this is showing how the
wind speed is decreasing the the path of
the projectile is taking and what we're
going to do is we're going to try and
hit a precise target so here we have a
target we started out with kind of a
random set of parameters and we say okay
we're 20 3.8 meters off what we're going
to do is we're going to try and minimize
the objective minimize the distance
between those two and what we're going
to do is we're going to just run this
for kind of 30 iterations to see what is
the what is the parameters of this model
that we should learn in order to kind of
nail on target and when we do that we
can get values that work pretty darn
well
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
try changing the wind speed here and
when I do that what we see is it's
really inaccurate right and that's
because the way that this thing has been
the way this thing has been trained was
for that particular wind speed right
it's it's learned for that for that
particular for that particular domain oh
I was expecting another section to this
sort of thing so the next section of
this should have been talking about how
we can make it kind of immune to the
wind speed changes
the typical the typical deep-learning
way of doing this would be to train
across all different kinds of winds
conditions and kind of have your model
be able to learn all the different
subtleties of this particular parameters
affect on the output and as soon as you
would step into something that's you
know a little bit different from what
you train you would get something that's
completely different one of the benefits
to having a system that can
differentiate through the entire
physical model is that it's able to
invert that physical model such that it
can be very general to the kinds of
parameters that are baked into that
physical model so you can have something
that learns such that you can just tell
it okay given this winds you know given
this wind speed etc give me the inverse
and it's able to work its way back
through the entire model but apparently
I don't have that particular section in
this notebook which is too bad it is
however in a blog post so there is a
blog post about this trebuchet work and
it will talk about that in enough detail
we have a second section here that talks
about using a neural network to actually
calculate the forward paths even faster
than it otherwise would where we can
take our instead of solving the
differential equation we can use a
neural network to actually solve the
where the projectile will land and it
doesn't much quicker than then the
actually solving the the differential
equation itself is it like 100x or all
right next so what it looks here like
it's it's quite a bit faster yeah I'm
sorry
it's the simulator it's all simulated so
we we throw a so we throw the rock we
see where it lands then we calculate the
loss and we back propagate through the
program that did the actual simulation
the simulation is nothing a differential
equation yes yes there's kind of a large
body of work of using Julia's
differential equation solvers alongside
our automatic differentiation because
they work well and you can do a lot with
that
since enough differentiating through the
simulator you're using the simulator
generate the data and then training the
neural network for the forecast yes
that's right yes for the forward pass
speed-up that's exactly right yes okay
any last questions yes just a quick plug
I'm in the process of revising the
reviving the distribution list for July
users and Microsoft which have become
defunct so if you're interested in being
on that list come sting me on the way
out I'll put your email on it all right
well thank you guys for your attention
[Applause]